[SPEAKER_00]: Jude and Paul Rivera walking back to their rooms.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's not, let's not call it a man.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're a little tapped out on like, you know, the arcane arts right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why don't you teach me how to do what you do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll follow you and you can bitch at me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe throw some brass bowls at my shins.
[SPEAKER_02]: And let's get into FURDS without anybody in FURDS knowing that we got it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean... No, this is instructional.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would actually like to know who's in FURDS, because I chase some disreputable fucks out of the...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you want to go to FURDS without being seen at FURDS and you want to figure out who's there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, rule 101 of stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: The more people you have, the much harder it is for stealth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so we're a two-man team.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doesn't get any more crowded than that, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Two?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, other than one, you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So... And I can levitate.
[SPEAKER_00]: So by the way, you have no interest in going to prudence.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: You might.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why can't I just send my homoculus, sir?
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: How far away can you send your homunculus?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we need to be in the alleyway?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pretty damn far.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it need to be a hundred yards?
[SPEAKER_01]: A mile?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pretty damn far.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to stand right here and you can send your homunculus and you can tell me who's inferreds?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think we can do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could I?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Less than the end.
[SPEAKER_02]: Remember if it dies, we gotta make a new one.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not on.
[SPEAKER_00]: So... Do you want him to know about the capabilities of the Mocula?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's already seen it.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you're smart enough to know that what Jude is doing is actually probing me for information.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not...
[SPEAKER_00]: He is not...
[SPEAKER_00]: He's trying to figure your secrets out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why do you want to go to Ferds, by the way?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's where I'm staying.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why are you staying at Ferds?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ferd's a good guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nooo.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a dirtbag.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nooo.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he's a dirtbag, I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Should I stay here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, if Gion hires you, but you don't stay here... Why would I stay under Gion's thumb?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're telling me.
[SPEAKER_01]: A poor elf.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: You stayed under his thumb for 20 years.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're telling me you won't want to stay in a place of royalty and palace where everything is... No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've slept in the saddle.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it looks like you haven't slept for days.
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks like you haven't slept for days.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, years maybe, someone said.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know about years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, so it's months.
[SPEAKER_01]: That closer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I like the fact that you're trying to get information from me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, what I'm saying is... About how long an elf can go without, like, sleeping.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's important for you to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're an elf.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I got pointy ears.
[SPEAKER_02]: I thought you hid them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do, but I mean, like, if you hang out with me enough, the pointy's probably gonna stick out.
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume you're pretty observant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I noticed, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, no, I don't want to go to birds.
[SPEAKER_01]: That just seems like a waste of time.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to learn to stealth, then, like... Well, let's stealth in on, uh...
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would we stealth on Geon?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because it's right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's easy, it's close, and you won't stealth in on Bird.
[SPEAKER_01]: No?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why do you want to do Geon?
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you trying to get?
[SPEAKER_01]: How about James?
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's stealth in on James.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you trying to get out of this?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm saying let's keep going.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're complaining.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's keep going.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I'm saying let's not do any of the arcane arts.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's not learn any of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about if we stealth in on that one guy, the alchemist guy, when we went to his shop?
[SPEAKER_02]: The one guy took you to a shop.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get me in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tell me what I'm doing wrong.
[SPEAKER_01]: No way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you're trying to figure out if I'm an evil saint, which I'm not, but I can't prove it to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what are you talking about, evil?
[SPEAKER_02]: Those guys, whoa, whoa.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're talking about the alchemist, the guy who sold me the map.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't say kill anybody.
[SPEAKER_02]: I said stealth in and observe.
[SPEAKER_02]: On who?
[SPEAKER_02]: The alchemist guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_02]: The alchemist.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the alchemist guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Weren't you with me in the square when we went back to the alchemist shop?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should ask him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, we can ask him.
[SPEAKER_02]: But even if it was the masked guy, why don't we try to find the masked guy before he closes his show?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then we'll follow him, and you can tell me what I'm doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, because he was part of the market on the other side of town, which is kind of rough going through.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well then, let's stealth in on John.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, what is with you and fucking stealth in?
[SPEAKER_02]: What I'm saying is that you have an opportunity to have the roles reversed.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you've been upset with how I've been teaching you.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not upset.
[SPEAKER_02]: You sure?
[SPEAKER_02]: You've been flipping me off for a while now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yanking your chain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not serious intentions.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, then call this...
[SPEAKER_01]: If I didn't enjoy your presence, I wouldn't have even wanted to learn from it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then let's call this a test of endurance.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've already been up for several days, you said I look like it.
[SPEAKER_02]: How many days you been up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's keep going.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why do you want to keep up?
[SPEAKER_01]: What is with you who are trying to get stealth with me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now you're pushing it really hard.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm saying let's switch tracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: To what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, look.
[SPEAKER_02]: Out in the real world, when you're not locked onto a palace for 20 years, shit just tends to happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: And when bad shit happens, it never just happens cleanly.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's one time and you're done after like a bad half day or even a bad day.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what I'm suggesting is that you're done with the arcane arts.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I get that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's not be done.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm saying you pick a target.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's stealth in on it together.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can throw a brass bowl at my knees if I fuck up on our stealthy men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, we'll do this.
[SPEAKER_01]: How close can you get to a guard?
[SPEAKER_01]: Whoever gets closest wins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you sure?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, let's put some money on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much money?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know how much you got.
[SPEAKER_02]: More than me.
[SPEAKER_01]: More than me, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: 50 gold?
[SPEAKER_02]: 100 gold?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, 100 gold pieces.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which cards?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have a question.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ending day of Porto Wilson.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys are talking shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you walk up the stairs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now,
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to continue his training tomorrow?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or are there other things you wish to do as well?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think there's other things I wish to do as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we're either going to do those other things tonight, which is kind of...